how's it going how's it going right -
right and welcome back to another
episode of Dark Souls last episode was
probably the most intense [ __ ] I have
ever experienced in videogames and
apparently we're just getting started
with this game so I'm excited to play
some more let's see how many times will
die in this episode it's trying to lure
me out oh oh no nevermind thought I
would say from the dragon are you safe
here okay we're gonna strip our armor -
maybe run faster
what no what
Oh what do I do
matching throw that snow and it one
horse up inside Omaha's Vega
oh you can go underneath him oh god what
the [ __ ] rats I'm poison what does that
even mean
all right I never came this far holy cow
three hours later all right what have we
got up here I'm sure it'll be nothing
bad at all is that a giant ass rat I'm
not going there
this is gonna be so bad hi guys he's
gonna attack me at any time and what do
I do
clearly [ __ ] oh let's go up here
awesome yeah
try fire I don't have fire hide behind
the barrels hey I'm surprised
[ __ ] what is he doing
you can jump it so can I see it take
that oh god oh god hey this is really
awkward and you thought I was gonna kill
you I wouldn't hurt us all I'm just
gonna go over here now yep that's what
I'm gonna die why is he running okay
okay
it's cool it's cool I can kill you guys
easy I'm not scared
what the [ __ ] is that guy I don't trust
that guy who is that guy try stealth
gentle gentle gentle gentle gentle
gentle gentle gentle attack end yes he's
not dead he's not dead yes he said he
said I'm the greatest a night shield
look at that [ __ ] shield look at that
sweet ass she of Maine boy your daily
wants me I'm a TV special faking it so
easy I'm gonna [ __ ] stab you until
you die night two head is that a good
thing or a bad thing
I'm gonna guess good not good not good
it wasn't good at all he may look more
badass than you but that does not make
him better than you use your cunning and
skill towards that your advantage it's
never gonna work oh man you know you're
supposed to be tough for some [ __ ] don't
you drink in my place since why that's
right that's right why not imminent
everywhere
and I died god I hate these [ __ ] rats
Nathan so [ __ ] much nice angle on my
junk okay let's become human and see if
that is good it's great I don't look
like Miley Cyrus without makeup anymore
I'm in Freddy head ah come on baby come
on baby
it's so [ __ ] slow there you go there
ya go you like it yeah yeah a little off
hey
I'm gonna kick you and then I'll stab
the [ __ ] out here
patience my pits patience this ass I'm
gonna get poisoned I'm gonna get a
poison you're not gonna get poisoned
today that was [ __ ] close man BAE was
smoking clothes man and he got his rat
friends that is adorable
dad it's adorable make your move
excellent move now you die now you die
today please I have appointments at 5:00
I gotta go get my hair waxed I mean I
look fabulous already but ya know
everything that counts so yeah I'm just
gonna take a lap ah God dad I got a move
and [ __ ] now all right make your move
son
actually I'm gonna kick you and then I'm
gonna [ __ ] stab the dick out of me
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh bad idea man bad idea
Oh baby baby it's why I wear that was
[ __ ] Leith main I think I'm funny you
guys are great it does not look good for
fields
Oh God not this [ __ ] again oh god no I
saw a man come here I'm in the air you
can do it
stop moonwalking for one second and just
[ __ ] come here I'm here stop
moonwalking oh god I hate you now taste
my ass
come here little dick sucker [ __ ] ass
nugget no walls to save your ass this
time you [ __ ] dick but it's not dead
I hate you jump attack you can't jump
away when I jump attack what about this
oh oh god he's crazy
jump attack that's right [ __ ] oh
and I'm gonna enjoy that cat tonight
chard you [ __ ]
no I did not Oh two nights
before dumping genocide I adorn you
majestic beasts I can't tell if I got
worse at playing or if the game got
harder trying to make this [ __ ] jump
work this time around that big [ __ ]
amazing
if I can beat this guy it'll be the 4/3
for this I've come so far in the game
but I can't kiss he [ __ ] boon walks
all right all right we're dead ha ha no
no why did I pull it what did I pull it
why did I pull it that was the worst
idea ever that was the Morse idea where
that was the worst idea ever that was
the worst idea ever that was the worst
idea me huh oh okay it's just a nice
it's just a nice
okay we can fight nights yes you may
have a badass armor but I have a badass
ahead you're not even writing proud of
it
don't you dare heel [ __ ] tell me I'll
mix by my heel I tell you to stop
healing yeah that's right
I'm a pillager titanate shard if you
know what I mean I'm sure it's fine is
that a knight oh [ __ ] you backstabbing
hey hey we can't fight you we must use
our cunning and waste you're ugly I'm
beautiful that's all I got Oh Annie a
gate is open I don't think still don't
think it's a good idea and I still a not
a big fan of this pouring
god I hate him it's just [ __ ] mean
okay
it just really mean but main does he
have a nice ass I'm gonna [ __ ] run
for it
Davalos [ __ ] dog oh you [ __ ] oh
[Music]
this game is [ __ ] scarier in the
horror game what did I tell about you
[ __ ] drinking out of my ass don't
heal don't heal in my presence pull that
knife in my ass you think yourself
[ __ ] cool don't you with your [ __ ]
swagalicious gear
oh it's I told you had oh that's [ __ ]
adorable oh yes swing in that wall see
how good that does you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] if I had a cape you know what I get
[ __ ] by now what do you do being a
[ __ ] dick that's what you [ __ ] do
all right where's the other one come on
come on come [ __ ] here I oh come here
oh [ __ ] on a stick in my dick three
hours later we are back please let there
not be another night here the time has
come for us to fight well aren't you
gonna use your [ __ ] heal know you're
not gonna heal like all the other [ __ ]
as friends it seemed [ __ ] bad you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right any more traps that I should know
about
it's bound to be something encircling my
ass
might as well heal what what do you you
got some [ __ ] polar bear what the
hell are you
oh god how the hell am I gonna kill you
oh god you take all my elves that's
ourselves for your [ __ ] ass holy [ __ ]
alright I hope you enjoyed it anyway I
am actually despite the rage enjoying
this game a lot so I hope you both keep
supporting this series leave a like if
you want more I really appreciate it it
subscriber come birthday and I see
breasts in the next 1000 bras love you
dumb [ __ ] like that oh ha de hablar con
let's caught something a helmet
thank the milk needs a [ __ ]